lupita nyong'o and Michael B Jordan
what's the deal with their flirty tweets
Plus Josh Duhamel supports his ex Fergie
while Chris Brown pops up to wish ex
Rihanna happy birthday
hello guys welcome back from Black
Panther weekend are you one of the many
folks who helped the marvel movie hit
242 million dollars in this holiday
weekend if you did what did you think
and if you have it run don't walk and
believe the hype because this movie was
so incredible you might have noticed
that in the middle of their global press
tour Black Panther star Lupita Nyong'o
has been pranking her co-star Michael B
Jordan with impromptu push ups it
happened at the Calvin Klein show at New
York Fashion Week and again just this
morning backstage at the view Lupita
enjoyed that one a little too much don't
you think all right so what's the deal
well Michael told us it's all part of
this elaborate onset bet that well he
lost we have this thing called on-site
pushup so if you could bet on anything
you could bet on throwing and you know a
cup into the trash can and whether I'm
gonna make it or not and and if you lose
they can give them out they can give out
push-ups whenever they want I mean they
can call you at 4 o'clock in the morning
you got to get out of bed and do a
push-up so it doesn't matter where she
is ruthless okay
I'm not gonna go into this specific bed
but meanwhile the two co-stars got us
all flustered after a flirty Twitter
exchange things heated up when Michael
tweeted Lupita then deleted this bring
them chocolate cakes back you ready for
round two hashtag you know you want this
and for some extra spice with Peter shot
back no dessert until you come correct
hashtag you know you want this and
hashtag you ain't ready well for those
hoping these two are romantically
involved I'm sorry to break it to you
but might clear the
revealing that it was all part of a
celebrity print show and TVs safer but
I'm with you guys I would not mind
seeing these two together well when I
wasn't watching Black Panther I was a
little off the grid this weekend but
when I plugged back in this was all over
my feet
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think the paint faces on the celebs
and players says it all yep Fergie faced
backlash for that jazzed up performance
of the national anthem at the NBA
all-star game on Sunday night and to be
fair
Fergie did acknowledge the criticism
telling ET quote I'm a risk-taker
artistically but clearly this rendition
didn't strike the intended tone and
today Fergie's friendly ex josh duhamel
offered some support in the form of
flowers Josh brought a bouquet of roses
to the singers LA home while dropping
off their four-year-old son Axl
yesterday on the card the words I love
you even though they split in September
after eight years of marriage and that's
when you know it's bad when your ex
shows up to cheer you up which brings us
to our next story rihanna turned the big
three-o today and celebs have been
flocking to social media to wish bad
girl RiRi a happy birthday
including her ex Chris Brown Chris
shared this childhood photo of RiRi with
the simple caption happy birthday as you
know these two have had a tumultuous
relationship it's been well documented
so you can imagine the kind of response
this ignited their range from supportive
fans still shipping Rihanna and Chris to
other fans simply not having it
everyone's got an opinion on this one so
what's yours given their history should
he have kept the public displays of
affection private or is Chris just being
a pal no response from Rihanna on the
birthday post just yet but last night
she instagrammed herself in a I hate
Rihanna t-shirt the caption last day to
make a bad decision and blame it on my
20s well we read you the baddest and
something tells me no one's gonna stop
you in your 30s alright guys thanks for
watching we'll be back with a new one
tomorrow so you know the deal hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel and
visit ET online.com slash daily day to
see these stories and more love ya